BACK IN ACTION AFTER THE LOSIMEH
SIDNEY CROSBY.
HE'S ABLE TO G
STEPS AND FIRES AND
GOAL EARLY ON AND. IN THE LAST .
DENIED BY
THE ROOKIE.
TO RODRIGUES,PS IT OVER TO MINU.
GIROUX STEPS YOU HAVE.
THE BACK PASS, KONECNY.
HE SCORES.
PRETTIER THAN THAT FOR KONECNY.
THAT'S WHAT IT TOOK TO BEAT
JARRY.
IT
AND MATHESON, AND ON-SIDE.
UP HIGH.
MATHESON HAD AUCK COME
THROUGH.
TIMING IS NOT PERFECT.
HE'S THERE.
THE DESIRE IS THERE.
A
PENALTY AGAINST THE FLYERS.
>> Steve: RODRIGUES OFF THE
BOARDS, CUTS IN.
IT
THE GAME WHEN
COUTURIER MADE THE
TO MATHESON.
OUT TO CENTER CENTER
THE CHANCE.
THEY GET IT, SHOOTS, SAVE MADE
OFF THE TRY
ACCEPT OF 79.
OF THE THE THIRD PERIOD.
CENTERING PASS AND LITTLE
OFF THER WITH HIS STICK.
[HORN]
>> IT OVER WHEN THEIR
STICKS MET ON A FALSE START.
HE TRIED TO BANG IT TO CARTER L.
GUENTZEL THERE.
HEY
LITTLE MOVE BY CARTER AND FARAB.
CAM ATKINSON.
THE FAKE.RACING UP IS LETANG.
CARTER WITH THE PASS.
>> Bob: KEEP LOOKING.
YOUR MIGHT SIGNED YOURSELF A
THAT'S ENOUGH